people of the internet retro reckon who
are here just a dad who loves games and
the stories they tell welcome back to
Harry Potter in the Order of the Phoenix
now a lot has happened since our last
let's play here because I tried to
record a little bit before the Christmas
holidays and man you guys I had a a cold
or allergies usually my allergies don't
get bad this time of year but something
was flaring up and I just felt horrible
so when I was going back and watching
man it it was constantly like me
sniffling you could just tell I didn't
feel great so instead I'm going to catch
you guys up on everything that happened
instead of you putting you through that
subjecting you to watching that so I
went to the DA and we taught them Lev
Corpus all right so we just do a little
up and then left right left right okay
just waggle waggle waggle waggle there
was also this incredibly awkward kiss
between Harry and Joe why is this
so
awkward oh my gosh it's
awkward I'm so uncomfortable right now
then we get the scene where Harry is
actually inside Voldemort's mind and
sees Nini attack Arthur
Weasley and as a result of that
Dumbledore decides that it's time to
start teaching Harry a clency of course
he's not going to teach him himself we
know why if you've read the books at
this point Harry has no idea why he's
making Snape teach him instead so we
start the aumy lessons and the gaml for
that was well four snapes W back to the
center to defeat
[Music]
him repeatedly tap r in the direction
opposite the direction okay wait so like
down I got you I got you I wonder how
they did this on the Wii is it just
waggle waggle waggle in which direction
though right then we have this baz
bizarre Christmas sequence at grimal
place and again I was feeling pretty
sick guys so I don't know if it's just I
felt so bad or if it was just really
bizarre strange gameplay here because
there were some things that I know there
were more secrets particularly in this
room with Jenny that I just couldn't get
them to work right ooh wait look at this
the
locket the
locket okay so you can lock on to that
one now I just tried
to basically tried everything see if we
can
nope you guys this is so strange right
now we do eventually make it back to
Hogwarts Hagrid introduces us to his
half brother grop this actually takes
place in a cut scene meet your new
friend
per then we get more aumy with our boy
Professor Snape I mean I get that they
needed to come up with
something for a clency
but this ain't it and from there that's
when things really start to kick off
because Umbridge and the inquisitorial
Squad led by Draco Maloy they find
Dumbledore's Army but I'm afraid I have
no intention of going
quietly so with Dumbledore mcgonagle and
Hagrid all gone Harry Ron and Hermione
our golden Trio here are up to the point
now where they're saying okay we have to
do something about this we have to fight
back against Dolores Jane UMD and what
do you know guys we got to round up the
crew we got to round up dumbledor Army
and why do I get the feeling somebody
tell me why I get the feeling that we're
going to have I don't know maybe some
fetch quests right here let's start with
Luna love good right here looks like she
is in this area where we're currently at
right now and basically you guys are
fully caught up so we're getting ready
to shift into the the end game at least
I think we are and what's so bad man is
I was so excited about starting that
last playthrough because I was like okay
we're finally going to get to do
something else besides all the fetch
quests and it ended up just being not
all that fun the dueling is really rough
in this game it's maybe it's cuz all of
the the wand motions how you have to use
the right analog stick over here oh
hello Luna let's talk to you the Weasley
twins gave me a message yes what is it
they said they've hidden portable SWS in
the courtyards they'd like us to set
them off there's one up there we've just
got to find a way to get it down and
into the middle of the courtyard come on
let's get that
swamp okay we've got to get the swamp
down into the
courtyard oh so that's what that X was
for there was also an x on the ground
yeah right over there beside the
fountain did you see Potter and Po got
another okay so how are we supposed to
get up there let's see if Luna gives us
let start Ping things up so we can
climb now that thank you that
is that is some good advice right there
let's try piling things up so we can
climb perfect Luna I love it meanwhile
several episodes ago Hermione and Ron
couldn't be bothered to come up with hey
maybe we should stack things on top of
each other it's okay we finally figured
it out we finally did but guys I really
hope you're enjoying this let's play
series uh if you are make sure to uh
leave a thumbs up on the video it's
going to help more people to find it so
we've got an x marks the spot right here
I wonder if we're just supposed to move
this over
here guardi
leosa oh oh sorry guys sorry sorry sorry
let's put it right there and I mean who
you guys could be watching these at any
point but I am recording these near the
very end of excuse excuse me oh there it
is I thought it disappeared I am
recording these near the very end of
2023 so I am in the middle of planning
everything that I want to do on the
channel for next year for
2024 and I am leaning pretty strongly
right now to all future Potter Let's
Plays actually going on our let's play
channel so if you guys have not yet
followed our let's play channel uh or
subscribed to it rather I'll make sure
to link it down in the video description
below so you guys can find it but the
way that the YouTube algorithm works is
um basically you want to make more
videos that are popular on your channel
right and I know there's a a a decent
sized group of people who are interested
in these Let's do let's do repair right
we need to fix other way maybe yeah
there we go we can do this but the style
of video that the are it's just it's a
style thing right it's a format so
whenever people see these hour and a
half 2 hour long let's
plays um the people who watch our you
know tip videos and ranking videos they
they don't click on the long videos and
so that sends a signal to YouTube that
these videos aren't great now over time
the swamp box must be in this turret let
me try a little uh maybe an incendio on
this stuff right here no okay he was
locking onto here to cast reductor on
those time reducto
okay put their swamp in the middle of
the courtyard to set it off that means
you need to climb down don't I need to
get it out first yeah there we go Luna
wait wait
wait so yeah we made the the let's play
Channel a while back and I've I've been
posting things on there
periodically so if you guys are really
really into the let's
play make sure you go and subscribe to
that channel I'm guessing the swamp box
needs to roll on that cross yeah can I
get down guys like can you you are near
something you can climb yeah we need to
climb back down
now and I'm thinking that uh the main
channel here retro and tour is just
going to primarily be you know our news
update videos tips
secrets to set it let's put the box down
on the cross okay actually somebody
already put it there so thank you but
now let's stand back pretty far away
from
it hold on how how far away can I get
and still
be well we're we're going for it no no
no no no Harry no no no wrong spell I
think reducto
is oh my goodness the lock on is so
strange okay right there are we on
it nice there we
go
that is too
funny let's see if homebridge uh how
soon she finds out about this I want to
know if we get to do the fireworks FR
and George really know their stuff they
said they'd hidden boxes in the other
Courtyards as well we should go there
and set those off too I think I'll stay
here and see if any hinky punks
come nice okay so wait she said I'll
stay stay here and see if any hinky
punks come let's see if that marks her
off it does okay so we're complete with
okay so that's not that wasn't a fetch
Quest that was we go to where Jenny or
excuse me Luna
was and then we did this little task
here all right all
right silencing
umbrage Colin creevy that's the allery
Dean Thomas that's pretty close to where
we are let's do
that let's see where does it want us to
go this
way I can't see the footprints at all
wait are they going this way
now what why didn't they just have us
walk across the
courtyard this way
okay Harry I've got a
plan let's hear
it
I've been thinking if we mess up the
clock in the clock tower Umbridge won't
be able to run her lessons on time but
how do we mess it up it's massive simple
we move a few of the cogs around and the
clock will go berserk come on Harry it's
genius okay gen do it I can't really
help not with being a prefect but if I
was to stand in the courtyard and keep a
lookout I wouldn't actually be doing
anything wrong would I let me know when
you finished Ron you're a prefect
too we need to get the clock running
backwards first we need to move all the
Cults over the way she said
that Ron you're a prefect too all right
what do you want me to do exactly are we
doing reducto on these
here talk please or just changing the
order like reversing okay he he he's
just he's not GNA say anything so Luna
very helpful Harry we need to stack some
things to climb up he's just like nah I
I I don't I don't think I don't think I
want to say
anything wardian
Leviosa oh
[Music]
okay oops I think we just need to I
think he said reverse the oh my
goodness I hear
Ron I hear Ron down there
all right so I think if we just change
these come
on and take you
up see if that reverses
it or did that just do the exact same
thing I think it just did the exact same
thing okay so how many of these can we
actually lock on to
oh maybe we need to put it on the other
side
here yeah yeah yeah that's what we got
to do I see now
cool I see now nope got to go a little
bit
higher a little bit higher not on that
one yeah there we go right oh okay hold
on maybe that one's too too big for that
spot
so maybe it needs to go here to this one
yeah there we go okay now if we bring
you over I bet you should fit right
here nice it's got to be it
man great there's got to be something
else we can do to mess things up try
looking
upstairs try looking upstairs okay this
is so
[Music]
cool
anything useful up there there are some
spare cogs great pass them down to
me pass down the spare cogs okay so this
one right
[Music]
here all right do you want me to just to
kind
of drop
itard yes he got it levosa let's
go
cool
[Music]
I don't know if he got that one or not I
didn't hear the
spell we'll just assume that he
did okay we also uh one thing I forgot
to point out in the last episode is we
had a really cool
moment one other thing I forgot to tell
you guys is we did have a pretty cool
moment with these bells right here
yes
all right let's go back down this is so
cool oops didn't go all the
way let's put the spare cogs in that bit
over there oh now we have to put those
on this side
okay okay so maybe a little one
first or are they all the same size
I think they
might all be the same
size oh wait no that one is is that
one's not hitting we need to take it out
yep right
here now this one that's on the ground
quick get it out now see this is
actually okay this is a big Improvement
I'll say this is kind of cool this is
starting to feel more like the types of
things you would have expected to see in
the
game I mean anything beats just she
might even have second thoughts about
getting her hands on Hogwarts the
monotonous fetch quests anything beats
that all right so he's crossed off
now yes all right so we need Colin Jenny
Padma perati both of them all right
so Colin is kind of close to us Jenny's
pretty far
away padman and PVA are pretty close as
well all right so let's let's knock out
colins's Quest right up
there and then we'll get the ptil Twins
and then we'll finish it off with
Jenny all right so just have to get
there
hey
hi Hey
listen Hey
Hey
listen
[Music]
I'm doing this so it'll go over the
copyright music and I won't have to blur
it out on YouTube
[Music]
hopefully
I know this sounds so much better to you
[Music]
guys hurry hurry over here oh there's
Colin all
right Colin looks like you've got the
fireworks over here hi Colin are you all
right no I can't cast the spell I need
the music to stop so it won't be
copyrighted
It's So Random like why is it playing
while he's normally I wouldn't talk
while he's talking but I'm trying to
override theyave me these boxes of Honey
J's chocolates to post to the
inquisitorial Squad but I can't even get
into the ower to send them I'll help you
what really yeah but why did Fred and
George want to send chocolates to the
inquisitorial Squad because they're not
really chocolates they're some really
really loud howlers as soon as the
inquisitorial Squad opens them they'll
get chased around by howlers shouting
really rude things at them Fred and jws
have brilliant plans we just need to
find a way
inside all right so it's not the
fireworks all right looks like we need
to incendio that
things come on incend there you go Harry
oh we have to keep doing it that's
right everybody get to
waggling you are near something you can
climb
right you were near yeah there it was
you were near something you can climb
okay what is it I think think we have to
go up here
maybe and can we hop up
here
[Music]
no there's no jump button so if you guys
are like why is he not jumping oh this
right here maybe there we
go can we just hop across now or do we
need to go all the
way
okay still
going there we
go isn't it funny that owls are called
owls like owls you could take your owl
to your owl how funny would that be can
you imagine their faces oh
boy we're just going to let that one go
just going to let it go that's it Harry
climb in there when you get to the
ground floor okay are you there there
okay Colin x marks the spot the I've
seen ever thanks now pass me those boxes
before Umbridge Catches Us okay we
Guardian Leviosa it's on its whoa way
did you get it we got it yeah thanks FR
of George said you need to put the boxes
into the empty ow holes we're already
ahead of you the ground Flor some
upstairs and some in the but I do
appreciate the the clarification I
do it's better than when they just say
hey do
this not specific at all all right
where's it at oh there it
is all right put you over
here and is that it or do we have
another spot I've done all the ones on
the ground floor oh we got to keep going
don't forget the ones upstairs we
leosa all right there's another box
right
[Music]
there I need another box Colin okay
where's this one going to land
Le hopefully right beside
us
or maybe okay first let's check down
here there it is
yeah Wing Guardian Leviosa okay so if we
put
it can we go all the way come on come
on come on little
Buck can you make
it okay what if I just leave it right
there no no no need another box Colin
okay bardian levos
it just completely rolled all the way
down oh wait here's one right here okay
hold on hold on don't depulso it Harry
don't take out your
frustration okay right there for sure
now maybe he's going to give us that's
it send me the last one that's brilliant
Harry wingardium
levosa does he send it right
here or a little bit higher yes okay
that is
Colin dude actually the perfect spot
man okay but this is bad can we just
there we go perfect it just knew where
we wanted to go done it I'm coming out
now nice one Harry this will show the
inquisitorial Squad wait Harry filch is
coming quick get to the window on the
top
floor get to the window on the top floor
you're near something you can climb is
it
this how do I get up
there can I go through here
maybe I can't get to the window it's too
high FR of George said I might need to
fix stuff look for something to repair
so you can reach the window
repair
raro oh okay it's like a little
ledge this perspective made it hard to
see are you staying I hope so Tak don't
I'll do what are you going to do Harry I
don't want to talk about thought you
saidil was
coming your whole life flash before your
eyes fell I wish my life was as good as
yours
Harry they did a good job with Colin I
got to
say I wish my life was as cool as yours
Harry poor Colin though do you think
about what ultimately happens to him
spoilers if you haven't read uh actually
I won't spoil it if you haven't read
Deathly Hallows but
it is not very happy for our boy Colin
let's just say
that hurry fil comes out quickly wait
can I not come on actually now that I
think about it he might be even more
annoying in the game than he is in the
book it's been a while since I've read
them but I don't remember him being this
annoying in the
books there we go yeah keep keep going
keep
going come on keep
going yes grab that go down
[Music]
again uh this
way dude where is Phil by the way is he
in the allery
[Music]
maybe almost there Harry almost there
all right now which way do we go this
way I was hoping we could just drop down
right there it looks like we
can't wonder if you can go faster I know
you can slide down
faster oh wait that might actually be a
little bit faster I was tapping
X see hold X or tapping X tapping
X oh dude I should have been doing that
the whole time's with the
Harry can you not oh wow that was
close what can we seriously not get down
right
here they're right below you man just
drop no okay I'm trying to climb off I'm
trying to go can you imagine falling
from up there how cool maybe we have to
go all the way around this way until you
hit the ground wouldn't be
good yep I see it
now come on go
Harry wait
what it's not letting me slide down
anymore okay hold on Slide
oh my gosh dude what is
happening right here maybe can we climb
up it's got to be this way doesn't it
okay hold on maybe they want us to climb
up again right here oh I think this is
how we came I think it's the exact way
that we came is we were up a little bit
higher because of the steps over
here then we should be able to slide
down oh oh my goodness finally nice one
Harry those of those inquisitorial
losers are right ear bashing you did
really well Colin I did thanks Harry now
get out of here quick before fil catches
you yeah of course thanks Harry wow I
helped Harry Potter Dennis is going to
be so
jealous all right so the ptil Twins and
then
Jenny all right so they're in the same
spot that's perfect
all right back into the Clock Tower and
on the lookout for the patil twins I
think we're getting pretty close
here hey hey hey there they
[Music]
are we need your help
we
uh-oh students are reminded that passing
NES in class is
prohibited I guess she hasn't found the
swamp yet I think we know how we can
sabotage them but we need your help okay
can you help us move that then you can
climb up and pour babbling beverage into
the l oh great more climbing good idea
isn't it great let's do it no more
climbing keep an eye out Harry you keep
a look out over there I'll go over there
so I need to stack things to climb up
pour something in there attention
children Hogwart students must not run
cast magic play tricks or SM in the
corridor Mr fil will be happy to instr
any student requiring a full list of
school rules is this enough do I have to
stack one we've made some more bubbling
beverage okay use the things you find to
make a way
across use the things you find to make
your way across oh can we repairo you no
come on turn around turn around there he
ISO I guess we haven't walked down this
Hall before or if I did I completely
missed the stuff
here might be good to power up one more
time to upgrade before we
wait I don't think that one gave us
anything did
it oh well it's
fine okay
so you need to climb onto that we did
yeah okay so we climb
up now maybe push square or
something nothing's
happening this is such a good idea maybe
we need to move it to where it's like
right under it that'd be very strange if
you just needed to move it oh it okay
they put it back over here for some
reason you're so
funny just making sure there's not
another one in here somewhere that we
need to
stack yeah I don't see another one to
stack it oh wait right there dude it's
so dark it was blending in thanks for
helping us har I couldn't see
it wow that
worked I'm going to the in not so well
ask
them okay now come on
Harry quick yes there we go close enough
thank you
you this is the high
Inquisitor I eat
frogs
what it worked go and make some more
babbling beverage so we can sabotage the
other speakers come and look for us by
one of speakers later
no why do you have a
multiart everybody else is just
done all right well let's see where they
go next
not not too far from where we're at
right now but Jenny is still further
away okay so we'll do that one next you
noticed stressed uh let's see and we are
going the right way
actually well well look where we find
ourselves ladies and
gentlemen once again we have made our
way to the ground staircase of hul wals
isn't there one of those speaker things
here oh right there yep
yep can you help us again Harry we've
made some more bubbling beverage here's
the potion we'll keep an eye out Harry
keep two of the little benches I see one
right
there wind Guardian leosa thanks for
helping us Harry come on that should be
good
enough and then this one right here
great
man I've been playing a lot of uh tears
of the Kingdom
too and just seeing how that game
handles when you're lifting and
manipulating objects how much control it
gives you then when you go to something
like this you just you have zero control
you get it in the general
direction then just press X and hope
that it lands where it needs to land
here the kingdom way more precise don't
take too long someone's bound to notice
the speakers are breaking all right so
hopefully only one more we've still got
four speakers left to
find I can't believe this all right well
they are kind of moving us closer to
Jenny as well so all right four speakers
left to
find and I'm not going to complain too
much because I mean technically I mean
they're sort of fetch Quest we're not
fetching anything but we're just going
from point A to point B doing the same
thing all right so I think we go down a
level see where does that want us to go
yeah go to this one right
here wait
what I'm so confused why is it wanted me
to go over here now is this literally
not what studious success a healthy mind
is an inquisitive mind sometimes I think
the the footsteps get confused they're
like oh no wait wait wait the stairs
moved we got we got to switch this
up let's look for the other there's one
right
there can you help us again Harry and I
already see the two benches that we need
to use here's the potion we'll keep an
eye out Harry Ron yeah stop talking we
got it now we we we've got the formula
now we guardium Leviosa thanks for
helping us har sorry look out look
out grab the other one over
here
great your attention please children if
you wish ask it stacked it in just the
right spot children raising
their be quiet UMD tired of hearing
about you strictly prohibited Mr filch
has a terrible smell
ter making
sense so three
more oh now that one actually is getting
close to oh very close to
Jenny hop
down seems like they're just they're one
of these on each level right now
studious success
you may pass Mr
Potter you guys have no idea how hard it
is for me to not repeat his voice in the
exact same way he says it every time it
pops up
like these Let's Plays man you really
think about when you first start doing
them it's kind of like you know I'm just
talking free flowing hanging out but
then the more of these that you record
you really start to think man I say that
a lot man that's probably really
annoying if I keep saying this or saying
that that is one of those things every
time he says it I find myself wanting to
repeat it you may pass Mr
poter our new celebrity oh here it is
right here wait where are they are they
not in here now are they just like
trusting me to handle this on my own
wardian
leosa be kind of crazy wouldn't it I'm
actually kind of worried that I glitched
something did I not finish something out
that I was supposed
to come on please work please let me do
it without them
here oh
no him any student found oh my gosh she
just
did will be
expelled okay wait so what is
this that's where I'm at but you serious
I have to go in order I can't do this
one right now even though I'm
here come on just let me
do now that is frustrating hopefully the
benches will stay though let's see if
they'll they'll actually stay in this
position for when we come back cuz so
far everything has just been nice and
kind of in the exact order that we
were going through the castle but
now we're going to have to backtrack to
that one after after we do this one oh
wait hold on did we have a where are
they there they are still going this
way I have no idea why but the Sprint
just randomly stopped working for a
second okay we're back we're back I've
got a new telescope want to come and do
that astronomy
homework isn't there a speaker near here
Harry why do you stop
walking isn't there a speaker near there
they are okay we've made some more
bubbling beverage
why don't you just give it to me and
then I'll go find you keep a lookout
over there oh we need Lookouts that's
why we got to have the
Lookouts come on Harry Guardian leosa
thanks for helping us
Harry all right where's the other one is
it blending in somewhere no it is right
there
great
the I can't believe it actually hold on
did it yes yes it's
there anyone given a detention
will be given extra butter beer for
free great we'll meet you by the next
speaker don't take too long someone's
bound to notice the speakers are
breaking Yeah you mentioned
that all right now the question is is
the one that we just went
to I think it is I think that's the
exact one that we were
at which means we should just be able to
go
exactly back track just where we came
from and hopefully the two benches are
still in place if not I mean it's not a
huge deal they're not too difficult now
that we've kind of gotten the hang of it
but it would be nice if they were
already there in set up yeah I don't
know what it is about that Hall maybe
the game's like kind of loading in the
background but whenever I'm trying to
Sprint through there it makes him stop
and walk each
time cross the bridge again there's a
speaker over there can you help right
here oh of course here's the potion of
course the bench is reset P that face
[Music]
Ron it's fine it's fine we'll do it
again wardian Leviosa thanks for help
where did it
go no not over there what in the
world no stop it keeps trying to go to
the other
side thanks for helping
har right there come
on auto detect please who oh oh and down
very nice I think it's just one more
after
this students are reminded that damaging
School speakers is
not an
offense come on one more one more one
more we'd better disable the last one
quickly
then all right one more left to
go oh that one's pretty far away Jenny's
actually right
there oh man this is so
tough yeah it's it's not going to take
that much longer I should just go wrap
this one up completely first
I don't think this game has any major
bugs or glitches but it's just
like I do not want to do this one
completely again imagine if starting
Jenny's reset this one although that's
not how the rest of the game has worked
you've been able to take on multiple
quests at one time so I probably
shouldn't
worry excuse me
hello hello can we all right there we
go not sure what was going on
there off on another adventure are we if
we go through that portrait again I'm
saying it next time we go
through I know I
said I'm going to try not to annoy you
guys with
it okay wait where is my
path this
way right
here I can't
isn't there one of those there it is can
you help us again we've made some
more all right the last of the Babbling
beverage wardian
Leviosa I think it's going to be close
enough let's find out Harry
please
Harry
Harry I know you can climb these this
will show that are you kidding me here's
the potion we'll keep an eye out Harry
Ron you keep a look out over here I'll
go over
there now now can we
CL children reporting your friends does
not mean you are to sne report your
friend today and earn house
points
this game dude this
game can be so strange sometimes I'm
sure we can all be
friends I don't think so that shut her
up thanks Harry yeah thanks I might even
forgive you for your behavior at the
uall last
year thanks see you later
Harry perfect okay so that should mean
that Jenny
Weasley is the final
task now as I've mentioned to you guys
before I am actually starting to think
that I never beat this game I know I
played this game as a kid but I think
that I must have just gotten so bored or
burnt
out I do not remember finishing it now
that's crazy for me because I hardly
ever played games without like it it
bothers me even now to this day to play
a game and not finish it poter I
need pass friend to I it's crazy to me
that I wouldn't have finished it but I
don't remember hey har I don't remember
going through this so I don't know if
we're about to start kind of like the
ingame stuff har or not so once we
complete this little scene here we find
out setting off portable swamps for Fred
and George yeah how did you I got the
next one down for you but then Malo sled
up and I had to hide
it okay oh I see another
X over here by the grass let's set the
swamp off okay you had to hide it in the
tree somewhere see the thing about the
Harry Potter games that were based on
the movies
is I mean we know how much story is left
but you never know when they're just
going to throw up a quick cut scene and
that's it
versus actually having you play through
something oh there it is I see it so
like we know obviously one of the big
scenes left is in the Forbidden Forest
the courtyard oh no you really don't
want to do that uh get lost uh you think
you're so good take this
Potter dueling time all right dude the
duels in this game they're I'm just not
a fan of them like it could have been so
cool but this is why I was so worried
about Hogwarts Legacy I was like they've
got to be able to nail the Bell
casting which they
did because here I mean it just feels so
awkward it's just it's
just it's just not
[Music]
good which looks like we're doing pretty
well right
now did we get them all right I think
we're done brilliant well done jinny
thanks Amion hey I helped too thank you
runny
one Jenny giving him a hard
time one
one wait doesn't hold on that's that's
actually book six is that kind of like
an Easter egg isn't it book six when
Ron's with lavender I'm pretty sure it
is and she starts calling him one onean
I don't think that's book
five there it is okay over
[Music]
there
and right there oh dude it's right by
those students over there they haven't
moved
so bye do it right when he walks
by py we
Porter are we glitched are we glitched
okay no the whole screen was meant to
turn green
all right let's see where does it take
us from here do we have a scene where we
play out let's hope this makes um
Forbidden Forest with
UMB swamped with complaints can we go
now do we do anything with the
fireworks cuz we haven't he hasn't seen
anything with Sirius yet so we haven't
seen the
the vision that he gets from
Voldemort all right there's currently no
tasks so I guess we just follow Jenny
for right
now we've just got to be siin at
quidditch wait are we actually going
to what wait we should find the da
members and make sure they're all right
what are you talking
about we just we just we just found them
all Hermione what do you
mean we've just got to be okay that's
all Jenny has to say now if we're going
to show Umbridge we should look for the
others on the
map I we did
that are we bug the's map right now see
where the are we
bugged
what okay it's it's got I'm not going to
panic yet I'm not going to
panic we just need to uh exit the area
or something okay hold on here's what
we're going to do I'm going to reload
the save I'm going to I'm going to save
and then we're going to reload it cuz
you know how it always put you in the
room of requirement maybe that will
trigger whatever needs to be triggered
all right we saved we quit out of the
game backed out to the main menu
reloaded and now we're here in the clock
tower
Courtyard and we have no task okay
here's there's got to be a place that we
need to go to trigger something that's
all I can think of like let's talk to
them
again that that part worries
me oh my gosh that they keep telling me
to find them and we're checking the map
and there's nothing on the
map okay so this is kind of My Last Hope
here I went online watched a walkthrough
of that exact section so apparently most
people are ending with the ptil twins
that's kind of the last one they end
with
and when you end right there in the
entrance uh Courtyard
area wait there okay there go the
footprints there's a moment where Maloy
tells you that Snape is ready for your
next aumy lesson that part never
happened to me so I'm going to go back
to that spot see if Maloy is there and
if I can talk to
him it seems like that is the sort of
triggering event that has to happen in
order order for me to get that next
mission so I've done everything except
for like that that mission with Snape is
what should sequentially come next so it
should be right out here so if you
remember we were sitting on or we stood
on the benches over
here and I do not see Maloy he's like
right here like right after they do
it in the video I watched they climb up
here they do it they jump down and then
Malo is like right
there this is this is not good
man this is not good I I don't know what
to do like is Maloy is he in the castle
somewhere like maybe we just have to
find him wait is that that's not Maloy
is it nope he's talking like Maloy but
it's it's not Maloy one eternity
later look for where FR George of HD the
swamp there it is me Harry they AR
making as easy are they wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait put them where your
mou would find me can you help me get up
to the first
ledge oh my
gosh I think we found it
guys this this was not in what I just
watched so apparently we
missed oh my gosh okay so I guess
whenever we were doing the one with I
can't remember who this was when we had
to find
these oh my goodness the swamps with
Fred and George was that like the first
one we
did I guess we didn't get the last one I
mean who knows maybe there's more but
why would that not show
anything on your
map oh my goodness
dude okay maybe we have saved
it maybe we we have saved
it where is the what are we supposed to
even do here oh wait maybe it's this
right here see let's repair
that if AMD catches us up here we've had
it yeah you stay here and keep I'll get
the box oh my
gosh oh my gosh you guys don't even know
like you're you're seeing this all just
play out before your eyes but I have
turned off the game restarted turned it
back on reloaded different saves watched
like three YouTube videos trying to
figure out exactly what people do here
messaged our boy
Dylan one of our mods here uh who I know
has a lot of experience with this
game trying to figure out what
happened and all we needed to do was
wander around enough apparently this was
part of one of the other Quests for a
student but why would it why would it
check it off the
list why would would it go away from the
list I was not about to replay through
this heck who knows maybe this happened
to me as a kid and it's why I never beat
it maybe it's why the game was largely
forgettable for
me that is crazy
though okay so I'm assuming now we just
need
to finish this one and that should be it
but maybe there's maybe there's another
one dude where are we even supposed to
go right now all right we climb the
metal pipe right there we hop over here
we go across this is all exactly what
you would expect okay wait maybe right
here maybe this is the spot where we
switch it
up can we get over to that
one all the way
maybe what I didn't know you could do
this that hn tail almost got me at least
there are no dragons this year unless
you count UMD I didn't know you could
could do
this is that a repair
thing
wait didn't look like it repaired
anything he said it
[Music]
but yikes hope you guys aren't afraid of
heights that that view right there all
right is that a dead end we can't move
the camera to see if we
can all right I guess that was just a
little Discovery right there all right
up you go Harry up you go now we should
be able
to
shees please just give me the Box up
here please where's the Box yes there it
is thank you oh my goodness thank you
now let's get this to the middle of the
courtyard now I'm curious though can we
go around over here nope
all right back
down it is actually crazy how long it
takes just to climb just to climb back
down wow so many little edits in this
let's play series just to make it a more
pleasurable viewing experience for you
guys trust me you definitely want me to
do
that all right now let's see what
happens because if we still don't get
any progress that means there's another
one that we're missing somewhere another
swamp anything
anything that was brilliant let's hope
UMD finally gets the message yeah
nothing says bug off better than a
portable swamp brilliant Harry that's it
set all the swamps off that should keep
fil busy for a while Fred and George are
going to make a fortune out of these
they're brilliant right let's see what
else we can do to upset
Umbridge hey Potter what do you want M
boy Professor snake wants to see you in
his office there it is time for your
remedial potions
lesson right that's the with you Potter
you think you're so clever but you can't
even work out which end of The Cauldron
like the fire
under oh my gosh yes thank you so
much thank you so much
Foy and well wait can we can we can we
get
out can we leave this
way let's get out of here all right man
time for aumy with Snape let's head down
into the Dungeons and then I think that
will really start to set up kind of the
final sections of the game I know for
sure that they've got to at least either
do a cut scene or we actually get to
play out the Forbidden Force sequence
with uh UMD and grop and all that
probably going to have a firework scene
with the Weasley twins as well I would
think and then from there probably going
to the ministry I'm just trying to guess
thinking thinking about the last few
you're late again Potter have you been
practicing yes well we'll soon find out
won't we wand out
water all right four snapes on back here
we go with the most
bizarre mini game
[Music]
there we
go
[Music]
enough your lessons are at an end I get
out the game really they don't George
want to see you they're on the fifth
floor they don't show you at all what
just
happened let's find Fred and
George let's find Fred and George you
know what I think that is an excellent
place to end this episode and possibly
finish with our next episode we only
have a couple things left thankfully we
got everything back on track guys thank
you so much for all your support on this
series hope you all had a wonderful
holiday season as always thank you all
so much for watching I'll talk to you
again soon